j'arrête vaut un homme
ah oui il a hésité mais moi oui oui on
est là pour eux une femme oui au pôle à
houla est d'origine entretenez-vous une
relation quelle qu'elle soit avec cette
femme bah oui bah oui bah oui c'est
imposer le principe avec l'assentiment
talent que vous êtes des formes et
se lâche effet le jeune habitat mystère
est ce que vous entretenez une relation
sentimentale avec une femme autour de la
table j
sais tu me ramènes sur le producteur de
l'émission s'appelle cyril hanouna
rémission est génial elle est d'accord
oui c'est ce que vous avez du poils sous
les bras
c'est un homme il c'est pile je ne sais
pas si ça de l'intérêt pour essayer de
trouver année c'est une enfant elle
avoue l'ex de ludivine ne leur était pas
à cannes et oui alex de magali
un premier indice pour vous aider oui un
premier indice s'il vous plaît en régie
premiers indices pour découvrir le syli
se cache derrière l'invité mystère le
passage en 2010 ni assez pour toi
c'était à dernier ce que j'espère c'est
leur en juin 2009 j'admire votre fille
oui mais c'est pas le 19 passez pas 2019
y accoucher avant
ben c'est comme à 32,69 c'est tout pas
je ne sais pas le même jour à la même
date pas la même année à peu près c'est
presque ça 20 juin 2013 serait dit
quelque chose à quelqu'un autour de la
table vous êtes le défunt de daniel
parsy je pense le sénat les voix les
données vous pouvez déjà donné naissance
à voir une réponse à la saga tatatata
pas qu'elle mettait tout de suite on va
continuer à jouer
alors je voudrais deuxième vingt dix ans
que je suis à côté de ça va vous vous
conforter dans votre réflexion hockey sa
deuxième injustice
et trédaniel
je sais pourquoi je me sens en marchant
[Musique]
peut-être êtes-vous venu vous venu
spécialement pour daniel
alors attention daniel est ce que ça
vous dit quelque chose cet indice le 20
juin 2019 plus ce slow cette chanson
destinée on était tous les deux mais
stimulé la dernière fois qu'elle a fait
la
nation me / gestion sont ici à midi
quelques slows sur le plateau c'est
qu'elle est à dire les koubéens
ont dû reporter tout le monde on va
regarder le troisième indice qui
peut-être mettra définitivement clément
d'accord êtres eh oui c'est parti pour
les téléspectateurs et pour ici sur
plateau
daniel et là je le reconnais évidemment
michel ya des indices qui me font que tu
me symbolique et très chaud zaoui
patrick mais patrick tesse patrick fleck
sosie de jean michel maire qui est
patrick sur la barre
[Applaudissements]
là
et daniel alors je rappelle un peu me
donné il est magnifique c'est pas très
franchement depuis 2002 n'avait pas
bougé alors oui je le rappelle à nos
téléspectateurs à patrick hamel vous
étiez venu le 14 mars 2010neuf c'est
cyril hanouna que j'embrasse très fort
qui nous regardent qui annonçait donc
que vous étiez en couple tous les deux
daniel les batteries le 20 juin 2019
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous vous êtes
placé sur le plateau de thé pmp mais je
peux vous dire qu'on avait une qui était
moyen moyen parce qu'elle est un peu sur
le dos
la baraque à frites et vous vous êtes
coûté quelques semaines plus tard et
cette histoire un peu est un peu parti
comme ça en eau de boudin et puis
patrick corré depuis quelques temps vous
regarder à nouveau pmp vous regardez
d'annuelles et vous vous dites que vous
êtes peut-être passé l'un et l'autre à
côté de quelques chemins oui
effectivement je suis pas je suis resté
deux ans dans une grange au milieu de la
nature et oui et quand je suis revenu à
civilisation je me suis mieux à la télé
j'ai vu daniel qui était revenue sur le
plateau est alors ma grande surprise
j'ai vu qu'elle tournait autour de
beaucoup de
ses intrigues sur tender vous allez ça
m'a déçu justement parce que je me suis
dit ah me donne pas de nouvelles et en
plus elle en train de draguer des hommes
son nom mais il y avait un médecine
d'heure et timber et n'diaye
bah oui
je viens de la voir comme je ne
comprends pas cela parce que sincèrement
votre petit coeur bat pour daniel c'est
à dire que vous vous dites quand même ça
ne me plaît pas delà de la voir être
séduite par d'autres hommes que moi oui
si je suis là ce soir justement c'est
pour que elle me donne une deuxième
chance bon alors c'est vous le deuxième
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est du genre dans une grange urbain
j'ai vu personne c'est daniel daniel
koch pour vous remettre un petit peu de
rencontres et pour que les
téléspectateurs se souviennent on
regarde quelques petites images le
patrick quand il était venu au tout
début de cette relation qui peut être ce
soir reprendra les sables les regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ce jeu contre adel jordanienne
sur la lancée moi mais je viens de le
pont pour le mène à tout pourquoi pour
compenser je vais prendre une pelle non
[Applaudissements]
alors
vous savez que j'ai dit que ce soir
c'était une soirée feelgood une soirée
bienveillante oui avec que des bonnes
ondes et que c'était l'amour sous toutes
ses formes l'amour voilà l'amour filial
l'amour
justement moi ce que je vous propose ce
soir daniel et patrick et patrick
patrick
je l'appelle maintenant je vais perdre
au départ le bijou là parce que le bisou
était incroyable je sens que vous avez
envie de vous reconnecter un tout petit
pain les deux mondes à nouveau de voir
si peut-être des fouilles quoi
en tout cas si tout est éventuellement
il peut y avoir
aujourd'hui plutôt réussi
c'est très symbolique cette flamme
c
est pour ça les équipes on s'est dit
qu'on allait vous concocter regarder un
petit dîner aux chandelles
en amoureux tous les deux voilà
[Applaudissements]
on a tout prévu de primes par point tous
les deux c'est de quitter le plateau on
vous a tout prévu à leurs pas et
délicieux je fais moi même les boulettes
dont
éventuellement de toucher d'autres
boules à fabre
près d'un pigeon les animaux vraiment
non non vous avez ces deux heures
d'émission
vraiment vous avez préparé mais à
l'école et on viendra faire des petits
points réguliers tournant peu connu
[Applaudissements]
non
m
regardez les ont bloqués
magnifique on leur en fait un petit
dîner en toute discrétion il ya eu 50
ans caméras
ils vont pouvoir parler en toute
intimité